and 48 hours of people and events that
help document the american story
visit cspan.org history for more
information
up next on book tv afterwards with guest
host chester gills the dean of
georgetown's college of arts and
sciences
this week william jerezowicz discusses
his book excellent sheep the
miseducation of the american elite and
the way to a meaningful life
in it mr derezowicz argues that the most
sought-after universities in the country
fall short of providing the key
components of a good education that
every student should have
lessons in how to think critically be
creative and maintain goals in life
after their university education this
program is about an hour
thank you for this insightful book
excellent sheep which has been
provocative in higher education circles
and i think among students and families
it's a terrific contribution to the
literature thank you and i'm grateful
for it i think the nation should be
grateful to you for it
i'll have a series of questions okay
about it
and i'll start with maybe the more
difficult one um
it appears you didn't receive tenure at
yale right uh you had a great run you
did wonderful work
you didn't acknowledge that in the book
i'm wondering why not
well
i think that that's a question that's
come more often from fellow academics
who wonder whether this book is a
product of sour grapes i think
specifically that comes from from people
in the ivy league i didn't want to make
my story part of it any more than i
needed to the book is really for general
readers for students for their families
perhaps in retrospect it would have been
a good idea just to get that out of the
way and i'm glad that you asked me so i
can get it out of the way
no one of any sense who's a junior
faculty member at a place like yale
expects to get down here at a place like
yale
i didn't
i'm not angry at yale for not giving me
tenure i left academia because i wasn't
able to get a job somewhere else and the
main reason for that is that jobs in
academia are drying up
because increasingly schools are hiring
adjuncts rather than professors so it's
really a larger problem that's part of
the things that i talk about in the book
absolutely true and i'm sympathetic to
that yes i just wanted to know i'm glad
i'm glad we are i certainly understand
that uh yeah that's a circumstance from
many many professors yeah
um
interestingly uh you know i'm at
georgetown so it's a jesuit catholic
university
and i had a particular interest in that
domain and you you only mentioned one
catholic university in this book
catholic university in chile actually
so i was wondering if you think that
none of the catholic universities in the
country either are elite or you don't
know that domain or we don't have the
same kind of student bodies that yale or
the ivy leagues have
no it's not that i mean i do mention a
fair number of schools in the course of
really talking about what students have
written to me and what fellow professors
have told me about things at their
school but it's to a certain extent it's
a bit arbitrary who i mention and who i
don't
uh it's not that i think the elite
catholic universities of which
georgetown notre dame bc clearly are
among
uh it's not that i think things are
radically different there because it's
all one system and the main
aspect of the system is
the kinds of students that are being
produced before they even get to college
it's really about the admissions process
now as you know i have sort of a half a
paragraph in the book where i say that i
think that in some ways
religious colleges and that would
include the prestigious catholic
universities do things better because
they're still paying attention to the
higher purposes of a higher education i
should say that that line about
religious schools seems to be one of the
ones that is most annoyed
ivy league professors
not not most readers
but people like stephen pinker who are
just
incensed at the idea that that the word
religious and the word good could be in
the same sentence
so
well i would i would tend to think that
religious schools and catholic and
jesuit schools do have a value added in
what they do
and i i think at our place that there
are we are trying i'm trying to shape
students for life
and i tell parents for example you've
given us a gem as any of these elite
schools have and we polish it and give
it back to you with a with a conscience
the responsibility to give back and the
ability to lead and that's what we do
and what i want your students to be your
sons or daughters are better versions of
themselves when they leave here oh
they'll also be smart they were smart
when they came in and they'll have a
georgetown degree or they'll have a yale
degree they'll have a harvard degree of
course that's a given for these students
it's it's it's what happens at the
margins and what i'm really at the
center of themselves is the more
important right than simply the
credentialing i think the credentialing
will happen and i think they've all
earned that right so that's really not
what i'm interested in but right
i realize families are interested in
this and students are interested in
credentialing as well but we have to
open their imagination to something
beyond that
listen i think the most disheartening
thing for me about the reaction to the
book is that i've said as you can a
simple paraphrase i've said
many of our most elite schools are not
giving students what i would call a real
education which is what you just
described
and the response has often been from
within those institutions or people who
recently graduated
not yes we do give a real education but
who wants a real education these days
don't be a sucker this is about job this
is about career this is about return on
investment and the kinds of things you
just talked about that it's about life
and not just about your job
uh this is an increasingly difficult
argument to make and it's one of the
main reasons i wrote the book to try to
push back against this
intensely pragmatic and i would say
self-defeatingly pragmatic
idea of education in general and higher
education in particular
yes i think for example liberal arts
schools
um are designed professional schools are
designed to teach you how to make a
living liberal arts schools that teach
teach you
uh how to live a life and why life is
worth living the larger questions and i
think i can give you an anecdote a story
of a student of ours who was an art
history major and was presented before
one of the boards at georgetown of
alumni and parents and so forth
and was being pressed
by
one of the board members why would you
do what are you going to do with that
what are you going to do with an art
history what are you going to do she
expressed how it's enriched her life
completely it will probably stay with
her for her life she has an aesthetic
sense it was
very eloquent very eloquent and he
pressed again but what are you going to
do with it and she said well
if i have to for a professional fall
back on my second major which is
neuroscience
and that's often the kind of students
i'm sure you saw but certainly that we
see and my own view is that i agree with
you completely you should pursue your
passion in college many people don't do
it i but i think you should pursue your
passion but i'm a pragmatist too so for
example
you can be a history major or an english
major but also i put in a minor in
business for college students a minor so
that you can know how to read a
spreadsheet and do because no matter
what you're doing even what i do i'm a
dean i'm doing management and i'm seeing
budgets right i'm an academic right by
training
so i haven't given up that core of who i
am but having other requisite skills is
helpful but it's not something i think
that that the liberal arts student
should pursue full time in undergraduate
experience right i want to be clear and
i hope i'm clear about this in the book
i'm a pragmatist too i do not want
students to think that the world is
going to
hand them a living because it owes them
a living
but
there's a difference between compromise
and capitulation right
figure out what you want to do figure
out what you care about the most and
then figure out hopefully with the help
of college
how you're going to translate that into
a career that can sustain you
but it's also i mean it's also important
for students to know that it's not just
about the first job and if you look at
people who've been successful especially
people who've been successful and done
interesting things it's almost never a
linear path
and that's why i say even in narrowly
practical terms
this pragmatic approach is
self-defeating because you want to
prepare people to be able to navigate a
career which means having all these
kinds of intangible or soft skills that
you don't get from a technical education
or from a business minor you get from
learning how to be the kind of person
and be the kind of thinker that a real
liberal arts education gives you someone
i heard recently described a liberal
arts education as intellectual cross
training that's a good term right
because it's not about majoring in
english per se or our history or
whatever it's about and only america
does this right only we allow students
to take classes insist that students
take classes across the curriculum so
they're learning different ways to think
and therefore they're better at each of
those ways because they've learned all
of the others i i agree i think it
contributes to a certain agility mental
agility and flexibility and and i
distinguish between a job and a career
and a career will last actually you'll
have more than one career most people
will have more than one career you might
be in multiple careers over your lives
you'll certainly have multiple jobs
and if the if the um
the measurement is exclusively your
first job and and the salary attached to
it it's probably not an accurate
measurement of where you're going to go
in your life if you measure liberal arts
people 10 years out and 15 years out
they they seem to do equally well with
people who are trained in other skills
usually on the financial i believe
there's a study that says that yeah but
the gap closes in about 10 years it does
close so i think and
for me these are four years where you
can explore a range of issues that i
think in my own view have intrinsic
value
uh not simply pragmatic value but
intrinsic value yes and that will that
will that will inform you and shape you
as who you are so i i we we couldn't
agree more on that one thing we try to
do
you also talk in the book about
how
practical and driven for credentialing
students are
and um not reflective often and i think
that's true i think they they get in
they they're on a treadmill to just get
to the next thing and fill the resume
out
we we try to have them
the judges call it contemplation and
action that you step back
and we we have a retreat center in
virginia away from the campus where we
take them and the retreat center doesn't
mean a religious retreat there are
religious retreats available but one is
called escape it's simply getting away
for a weekend and reflecting on what are
you doing here
why are you in college what does it mean
independent of the pressures from your
peers right there you'll have a small
peer group with you and someone to guide
the conversations
but also away from your family and away
from
what you've why
those those weekends are transformative
for many students they kind of figure it
out i think oh this is this is this i
need to do this more often
i need to reflect
i i believe that they're transformative
i think it's great that you guys are
doing it i do wish that i had mentioned
that in the book that i had known about
it and could have talked about it
because listen i mean what i do say is i
don't have a lot of practical
suggestions to make because i don't know
you as an individual right of course but
the one thing that i say is you need to
step away whether that means a gap year
before college i saw that or whatever it
is
it's it's precisely the act
of getting away from the peer pressure
the parental pressure the the incessant
business that comes with the the drive
to credential to credentialism the hoop
jumping right
now college in general
used to be should be is supposed to be
that in itself right college in general
is supposed to be the four year time out
right but it's been so pervaded by these
uh by these pragmatic pressures by these
this this credentials arms race
um
it's i insofar as i blame the colleges
for that it again goes back to the
admissions process and how it creates a
childhood and adolescence that's all
about jumping through the next hoop and
then secondarily that i think unlike
what you just described at georgetown
many colleges and i think many
especially elite colleges don't do
anything to disrupt the momentum of the
hoop jumping i think that they think
that because our kids are so smart and
of course they must be smart because
their sat scores are high they must be
smart because we let them in
then we don't need to do any of that
work of getting them to be reflective
about what their education is really for
they take it for granted i think that's
a huge mistake yeah i agree i think it's
a huge i think i think with that's
value-added we have to do that yeah we
have to force them into that kind of a
thought process
that kind of reflection that kind of
conversation with others about what is
the meaning of all this i think it's the
foundational question you have to do and
we have to come back to it again and
again it's not always easy and you're
fighting against certain pragmatism and
they're also
diffused in all their interests they're
doing many many things as you know
they're they're doing internships and
they're they're uh they're volunteering
and they're taking
five courses and they're in three groups
and they had two of those groups and
this is this is uh typical of it what
would you say for the strategy when
you're talking with families and all
uh and it's easier to do it at our place
than it might be at yale or other places
i'm not sure of the double major so for
example i often advise students listen
pursue your passion in college and you
said in the book yourself pursuing your
passion people don't do it as much
anymore i still think you should because
there are four very privileged years you
can never get back right and you'll
never have a chance to do this kind of
reflection again and the kind of reading
and and writing that you'll do in
college
but pursue your passion in one major and
do
do mom and dad's major if you want for
the second major or the one that's going
to set you up for a professional career
i'm fine with that i'm fine being an
english major and a biology major you
really want to be a doctor but you want
to be kind of well-rounded well-read
thought right
what do you think of that well i'm not
against it i know it's become very
common the kids will say one for me one
for my parents right
i'm a little skeptical about it um
again it can be the right choice
but i think it it misunderstands the
role that this passion or interest is
supposed to have
i don't think it's something that you
should just do on the side because it's
a neat thing when you're 20 years old
but you're you're gonna
you know it should be the foundation
of what you do in life
again compromises will have to be made
i've made compromises i'm sure you've
made compromises the world will demand
that of you but i think we need to start
from a place of
i actually try to get away from the word
passion because it's partly become such
a cliche and students feel like oh i
don't know what that feels like i prefer
the word purpose
because that unites the inner with the
outer what what what what what do you
care about and what do you see out there
in the world that needs your attention
to the extent that it's possible and
this will differ for different kids
different circumstances that is what
should motivate what you study in
college and what you do afterwards so
i'm not i don't like this bifurcation
right i mean that's exactly where we
start to get into trouble where we think
that life is over here and work is over
there
the idea is to find the kind of work if
you can that's going to
that's going to reflect what you care
about most deeply and listen there are
also surveys and i think common sense
tells us that that's also going to lead
to the most successful
even in vocational terms kind of
existence you know if you want to get
out of bed and do what you're doing and
it's meaningful to you
the psychologist will also tell us that
the two main
constituents of happiness our
connectedness to others
and a sense of purpose which which for
us
in the 21st century generally means
purpose through work
right this is true right something
that's purposeful and meaningful work
yeah and that has the remuneration is
good or maybe excellent but you have to
be doing something that's worthwhile
yes doing good while doing well in a
sense yes we would hope
um shifting a little bit there's so many
ideas in the book i have
my head is filled with things i want to
ask you
and one is the great inflation issue
i think at all schools across the board
but not necessarily every school i think
certainly the elite schools clearly
have heavy great inflation yes uh at our
own place the students are even
complaining about it ironically really
yes they are they're saying
we want a clearer differentiation
between who is really outstanding and
who is good
and we're not really getting that from
our grades uh the grades are very high
for everybody and so how do we how do i
know if i really am not staying that i'm
outstanding i mean i don't know i'm
meritorious more than the next person or
i stand out in any way
if we're all teeth on a comb on the gpa
scale
it's interesting they've said that now
as a consequence when they say that if
their gpa goes down they'll be the first
ones to complain and say right we didn't
mean that we didn't mean it would affect
me but it's an interesting argument
because
increasingly
a large number of students are gaining
latin honors at all elite schools very
high very high percentage of them right
many of them who marry it they come in
highly qualified it's not unusual but
we're thinking about
restraining that a little bit and
students are actually saying some are
saying that's a good idea others are
saying oh i might be left out and
therefore i won't be competitive for
graduate school or or profession
your take
well i first of all that's such an
interesting thing
you know because because as you know um
uh princeton
uh went back tried this they tried this
and and
despite the fact that apparently there
was no evidence that it was
disadvantaging their students after
graduation the students were so freaked
out by the possibility that it was that
they insisted that they go back to the
old inflated grade of you know the
average gpa like north of 3.5 right
uh
what's especially interesting to me
about what you said about your students
is that it it it resonates with with the
sense that i had as a professor
and i've had uh speaking to students
since then
that they
they want honesty
they know that the system
they've become so cynical about their
education
because it's always been so much like a
video game like just get to the next
level
and because they know
listen one of the things that's driving
great inflation is precisely this this
ridiculous busyness this extra the way
extracurriculars expand to fill all the
available space whether in college or in
high school how do students deal with
that how do you deal with the fact that
you're doing 10 different things sport
musical instrument whatever and you
still have to carry a course load
you put more and more pressure on your
teachers in high school or your
professors in college to inflate grades
but this but this is part of what
contributes to the cynicism and the
sense that students get that they're not
getting real feedback and they don't
really know where they stand right and i
found students often to be surprisingly
grateful
for honest feedback which i try to give
them you know which i think is good and
honest great hard grades i think the
best professors
are very good pedagogues they're very
good they're inspiring teachers and all
but they're also demanding
and i found the students who have find
that they got b from this person the
only b they got they think it was the
best course they had yes whereas the
easy a so to speak is it's okay but you
hear that a lot you hear that from
people who've been out of school for ten
years that's the professor they remember
these are the ones the most but again
it's an exception and as you say great
inflation is an increasing problem and
it speaks to the fact
that um
learning
is not at the top of the agenda in
college anymore yeah that's it can be a
problem it can be a problem i mean you
know people also talk about the mutual
non-aggression pact between students and
professors right right right
collusion among the professors sometimes
well because professors are incentivized
not to teach but to do research so it's
easy it's much it takes much less time
to give someone an a than it does to
give them a b because if it's a b you
have to explain it to them and then you
have to help them get better that's
right and that's the the key part and i
think that's the important part is
helping them get better
i mean
for example the whole notion of a
rewrite which
is a good idea i think
for something absolutely because that's
how you look absolutely okay here's your
mistakes let's try this again yeah and
but it's a it's it's it takes a lot of
takes a lot of work it takes it takes an
investment in the students and say if
that's your primary mission you're
really there to enhance student learning
yeah yes but if
usually most places have a dual mission
of of course
enhancing student learning but also
producing first rate scholarship it's a
challenge look look this has been a
contradiction in american higher ed for
a very long time
uh there are forces we could talk about
them
academic job market forces that that are
making it worse and worse
and as students shift their attention
away from their curriculars to their
extracurriculars
it becomes more and more of a problem no
one no one is really no one's primary
interest is what's going on in the
classroom the professors want to be in
the library or the lab the students want
to be in their club or their internship
so uh
we we need to think about we really need
to think about this yeah that's probably
exciting to say no one there are still
people who care about classrooms yeah
right performance but i know of course
but the direction is that way
um and speaking of that uh curricula and
all
what do you think of the um
the
the efforts to uh
change curricula through technology and
moocs and and all that's happening in
that kind that
wide domain you don't address it too
much in the book but i'm sure you have
some opinions i have a few choice
paragraphs about the books but i don't i
mean as you pointed out i try to cover a
lot of ground because i want to describe
what i think is a large system that
needs to be the parts need to be
inventoried
but i can't talk about everything i
don't want to try to talk about
everything
look as a general rule surely there are
ways that technology can enhance
learning
as another general rule
i think americans prefer to solve
problems with a machine than with a
human being
we prefer
technology to
teachers or psychologists or
sometimes even parents
education is a is a human relationship
it always has been i really think it
always will be i don't think we will
ever be able to teach people as well
by turning them loose on a computer
program
then we will
one-on-one in small classrooms with
teachers who are who are rewarded for
for teaching
people think that they can solve the
cost problem in college governors
politicians think that they can solve
this problem
with moocs with massive open online
courses with technology with
efficiencies of scale
i think it's a huge mistake and as i'm
sure you know the the
completion rates on moocs are dismal
they're in the single digits
even among the people who finish moocs
they tend to be older people who already
have college degrees yes the vast
majority of them have degrees already
they have degrees because they do it for
personal edification rather than it's
not the democratization of education
and making it more accessible to people
it's not about the kid in outer mongolia
that's going to get to mit right and
it's not just that they're doing it for
personal enrichment they've been to
college so they already know how to
teach themselves true the whole point of
college is to learn how to teach
yourself this is
very true but you can't you know you
can't do it by yourself no
um
another slight shift again um
i i had a transfer student whom i was
talking to at georgetown wonderful young
woman
and
she had come from a school that was
should i say this sounds arrogant not
elite but it was certainly
it was a very ordinary kind of place
yeah
she was very bright she had gotten into
several very good schools including
georgetown and colombia and chicago and
but didn't have the money yeah and we
gave only the financial aid we could
give and it wasn't enough so she went to
another school thinking that
a good student can get a good education
anywhere yeah and she found it not to be
true in the particular place she went to
she's come to us and it's been a much
richer environment right uh both for the
pedagogy but also i think for the for
the peer group that she's with and that
they're actually serious about education
that they are ambitious that they work
hard that they do their reading or all
of that they're conscientious right it
makes a difference the environment is if
if you want to be academically inclined
this is okay this is a culture where the
other culture was it was not a good
thing to be academically inclined so i'm
not sure that it works everywhere i
think in other words elite schools do
have something to offer
to students
listen uh
uh i i don't disagree with that i mean i
don't i'm not gonna romanticize or
idealize
public higher education as it exists now
to me the ultimate solution is to refund
public higher education to to make once
again the commitment we once made to
have high quality low or no cost higher
education public higher education
but given the state that things have
reached at most public universities
because of the relentless defunding
yeah i mean kids have trouble graduating
in four years because they're closed out
of classes classrooms are giant lecture
halls there's there's no contact there
aren't even graduate student teaching
assistants
um
the
elite private schools are very
well-resourced institutions and they
they can offer students the opportunity
i would i would even say they always
offer students the opportunity to get a
great education but at a lot of schools
and it sounds like georgetown isn't one
of them but certainly a lot of the ivy
league schools are like this
you have to fight to get the kind of
education that the school is supposedly
set up to give you because your peers by
and large are not interested in what's
going on in the classroom and your
professors by and large do not want to
take the time i mean people have written
about people at harvard have written
about this people at uva have written
about this one of the public ivs you
have to fight your institution
and i'm simply saying first of all
that's ridiculous and second of all
there are schools where that's not the
case i i single out as an institutional
model the liberal arts colleges
colleges that don't have a large
university edifice were where the where
the em where the emphasis is more on on
teaching
and they still
defend the liberal arts
a lot they're also now public honors
colleges more and more of them that try
to replicate that model on large uh
public campuses to me that's what a
college should look like where a student
feels supported by the institution and
their peers for wanting to get a real
education not like a sucker
because you should major in econ and go
to wall street
the advantage potential and all the
small liberal arts colleges that do that
i admire them they do it well and the
elite ones get the best students
but the the advantage might be for a
student who goes to a research
university that has a liberal arts
community within it they get they get
both in a sense they get access to
high quality research and a high power
institution in that way and they
hopefully get the personal attention and
the
teaching that is required in a college
environment right it's a balance but
there are some places that try to try to
do both listen
institutions differ i think of the
university of chicago which has this
great great reputation for intense
intellectualism i also think about the
fact the university of chicago seems to
be departing from its mission and i
don't know if you want to get into this
but be careful
well listen i mean you should be
concerned about this and i hear this at
other places too brown which is of the
ivy's the one that's most like a liberal
arts college i hear there also there's
an institutional convergence there's an
institutional homogenization partly
driven by u.s news and various other
practical factors or not practical
factors where more and more colleges are
looking more and more like each other
and and they're converging on that
research university model
in the in the worst sense where
it's all about research humanities gets
shrunk
as you know until it's small enough to
drown in the bathtub because science is
what brings in the money or supposedly
brings in the money and so forth yeah
they they do look homages i mean chicago
i went for graduate school and it's a it
was at that time two-thirds graduate and
one-third undergraduate so it's a kind
of a high-power research institution i
think it sees itself that way it has put
more resources in undergraduate
education and probably done a better job
in recent years
but i think you better be singly focused
when you go there
what you're going to be doing well it
may be true with the other schools too
yeah i mean i don't know if we want to
talk about chicago too much in
particular but i i see it differently i
mean it's always had i think a deserved
reputation for for for a very again a
very intense intellectual experience
sort of like a graduate school for
undergraduates exactly you know that's
that's what they seem to be moving away
from because a lot of kids don't want it
and you know they've changed their
admissions policies and dropped their
acceptance rate very far and they're
very happy about it but it seems like
the ethos that made it its own unique
place
uh
is getting lost well that's something
good saying something that's unique
since there is a lot of homogenization
across higher education to be unique is
not easy to do to be distinctive i think
you can be distinctive still
and some certain places are
um
but unique is probably not a term that
we would use for higher education
because we do look a lot alike many of
us it doesn't mix i mean maybe you can
explain this better because you're in
the at the management end but it would
seem to me that you would want to have a
differentiated product absolutely i mean
at georgetown i say because we're
jessica and catholic we're in washington
dc we're not berkeley we're not brown
those are wonderful institutions right
we're happy here's who we are we also
have an embedded value structure that
we're very clear about and it's us
one of the phrases that the school is
men and women for others so we expect
you to give back it's just part of the
culture this is who you you yeah yeah
this is to give just to the large to the
common good is what we expect of them
when they come in as freshmen they may
when they leave a seniors they
understand what that means as a
consequence
one of our biggest employers is teach
for america you'll do service for two
years and and some will stay in the
education domain but others will go on
to other things i think it's a good
thing people are actually doing
something worthwhile yeah the post
graduate
world
would you advise sometimes for example i
advise students who want to pursue a
particular passion we have this is
happening more and more for a media
industry they want to go to hollywood
they want to be screened right right
right i think that's okay i say go for a
couple of years put parameters around it
and if you're getting coffee for a
director eight years later you've got to
get out of it but at 22 i think you
should experiment i think you should be
i agree you should be free to do things
and not feel constrained that you have
to go immediately to get your mba or
your jd uh right as some students feel
right again it'll depend on what
circumstances dictate and maybe your
student debt load will dictate but um
listen you're not you haven't
experienced the world yet until you get
out of college so uh how are you going
to figure out what you want to do in the
world until you have some exposure to it
i agree with that um and especially if
we're talking about you know a law
degree a business degree
uh it's i think much better done uh when
you're a little bit older i agree and i
think maybe taking a little bit of a
risk is a good thing at some point it's
okay it's okay i mean you don't want to
take the risk when you're 35 and you
have a mortgage and you have a family or
you have responsibilities but when
you're 22 you can not just a good thing
i think it's an essential thing yeah and
part of the problem is right these kids
have been taught to be
risk-averse from the very beginning
because they know that they have to get
that perfect gpa to get into the name
brand college i mean risk aversion is
one of the things that people who've and
i'm not the first person to write about
this right
it's one of the main things that people
have identified for a long time and i
think it's something that we really need
to worry about just one quick thought
we're preparing students for an
increasingly unstructured
job market economic world with an
increasingly structured education
right so this is not serving them well
um
what about the professoriate how do you
think that's changed in the last 20 or
30 years no educational professor yeah i
mean
it contains its own melancholy
um
[Music]
i think the most important thing to say
about that
is that at this point only twenty-five
percent of people who teach in college
are professors
our tenured are tenure-tracking tenure
or tenure track professors the rest are
adjuncts post-docs graduate students or
a very large class as you know of
um
this is a way that schools have gotten
around tenure without saying that
they're abolishing tenure
listen a lot of these people are great
teachers i would say especially the
full-time right you're an adjunct you're
teaching at three or four places you're
getting 5 000 of course it doesn't
matter how committed you are to teaching
it's going to be very hard for you to be
a good teacher these longer-term
contract employees are often the best
teachers on campus
but they're still not rewarded i mean
salaries are still low
uh job security is low uh institutional
validation and prestige i mean everybody
knows that they're second class citizens
i think it's time that we got serious
about the idea of a teaching faculty in
parallel with a research faculty or i
mean
either or right you are
hired promoted and tenured either for
your research or your teaching or some
combination of the two
not just research as it is now
we already have this second faculty
but we need to uh we need to give them
the you know we need to pay them and
and and respect them
uh equally to
the research you know the research stars
i would agree i think we need to accord
them the respect and give them the
visibility for their career give them a
commitment from the institution to some
degree and they will be more deeply
committed to you and they often are
deeply committed to you
the other part the research i would i
would like to still the research factor
to be active in teaching i think that
they should be doing both i think it's
strictly a research faculty you really
have a two-tiered structure and a
two-tiered university and
and sometimes those who are the research
stars are they never see a majority of
the students they they're right their
classes are small they're harder to get
into they're graduate only
and therefore students who know they're
there don't have access to them i'd like
to see
my ideal is you teach at the
undergraduate level even introductory
and uh and an elective and you teach the
graduate level you do both
and not not exclusively one or the other
i mean only teaching undergrads when you
want a graduate seminar with with high
power students i get that right only
doing that and issuing the undergraduate
enterprise and
saying others can take care of that it
won't take care of itself i mean we need
really bright
research active uh cutting-edge people
in the classroom with our college
students right
but i mean you know the economics the
institutional structure has been pushing
me up in the other direction look i mean
why are there's why what's
what's caused the adjunctification of
the faculty
it's a cost-saving measure for
universities
uh
as i understand that the the segment of
the academic budget that's grown at the
slowest rate is institutional costs i'm
sorry is instructional costs in other
words there's you're not spending that
much more in teaching than you were 20
years ago
the football stadium the football coach
the football team
uh
the fancy dormitories the debt on the
money you had to borrow to pay for all
of these things
it has to do with this move to a
consumer model right we now see students
as customers who have to be appeased
what's going to appeal to an 18 year old
to get him to bring his tuition dollars
to our campus
listen these are long-term structural
problems there are also problems people
have been aware of for a long time and
it seems that all they do is talk about
them
but you're also this is from the
administrator yeah
you're also providing a large
infrastructure for people you're
basically providing a city yeah where
you know
a profession doesn't require that you
with the exception perhaps the military
that you have to house your people and
feed your people and entertain you and
all the things that a university is sure
to do these days so it's a big i'm not
saying yeah it doesn't have to be
elegant but it has to be present yeah
you need to have dorms but that creates
a culture for people to to be in no
listen i mean you need you need dorms
and you need cafeteria right the
question is what what level is it
exactly yeah how elegant and all no but
it's not as it's it's not as uh
immediately obvious to the eye
when you have the equivalent of of a
dowdy dormitory
in the classroom in other words an
adjunct professor who's you know that's
true that is not as evident
but for some people in the public they
don't understand what it costs to run a
university i mean i know they're they
they say this runaway cost we go beyond
inflation for our for our increases
sometimes but it's a very resource
intensive
enterprise to run you know it's right
it's expensive most schools end up
spending more per student than they
actually charge intuition even though
most people would not know that no i
know
and i think people also don't have a
lost leader should we say no it's true i
think people also don't know that real
costs for students have actually been
flat at private universities for about
10 years right i mean tuitions have
increased but the actual
sticker price that they're paying has
has been it's been almost flat for 10
years it's continued to rise quite
significantly at public universities
because we're defunding them right we
are and i get that and public some
public university presidents will say
i work at a state regulated but not a
state-supported university and uh and
that's changed very much since the land
grant university time uh
unfortunately because we have very high
quality public universities in america
many of them and uh and they're
underfunded and it's difficult to do it
so therefore
it's carried on the backs of
out-of-state students yeah paying the
higher tuition yes
listen to me this is the most important
issue
it's the fact that we have transferred
the burden of paying for higher
education from the taxpayer
to the student and family
so instead of taxes we have student debt
and if people want to see who's
responsible for the trillion plus
dollars in student debt they should go
and look in the mirror
no really this is imagine the taxpayers
won't agree with you on that no of
course not because taxpayers want
something for nothing right so we're not
spending on our physical infrastructure
and we're not spending on our
intellectual infrastructure so what do
we think we're going to get
people need to make the connection
between what happens to them as
taxpayers and what happens to them as
parents well this is the dilemma also if
you live in a state with a very fine
uh public university
and it's competitive then and you've
paid taxes and then your kid can't get
into that university because it's now
become elite
that's another issue you've paid it and
now your student doesn't have access to
what you paid for
i hadn't thought about that but uh i
would argue
i would question the idea that there are
any school any states
that are supporting their public
universities to the extent that they
should
well i mean look at the university of
california which was this you know
it's facing severe hardships financially
yeah yeah and downsizing in some cases
and raising tuition but yeah other other
state structures too large especially
large structures with that are very uh
capital intensive it's hard to keep them
going
um that's why we're at the elite schools
isn't it
well and it's also why there's such a
crazy stampede to get into the elite
private schools this is true
as long as the elite private schools can
provide
justice yale and georgetown need blind
meetful need so that the kid who comes
from a somewhat disadvantaged
economically disadvantaged background
has access to this education which which
for me is a moral value i think i think
it would be shame on us right if
georgetown is not open to all students
and not simply the economically elite
well it is but at the same time these
schools have very low admissions rates
right so
families know if i can get the kid in
then it'll be taken care of but that's
that's the whole point it's a narrow
gate to get them can you get in and i
don't think we'd have the same pressures
if parents knew that they could send
their kid to uva or berkeley or wherever
for nothing and not just or for you know
a thousand dollars a year
and not just uva or berkeley you know my
slogan now i believe china had a slogan
of 100 harvard's they're going to build
a hundred harvard equivalent i think we
need to build 100 berkeleys
we need to have two or three of those in
every state
so we don't have every high school kid
in america competing to get into one of
12 schools and some of those princeton
for example you can go for free i mean
if you get it right because that's the
financial aid policy is so generous and
the endowment is so rich yes but if you
get in true so you want acts
greater access but you also want
standards for these schools so they'll
still be competing well sure well that's
why i don't want us to have to rely on
those schools i mean let's be clear
about this for the low-income kid who
can get into princeton or harvard it's
amazing
uh it's like three or four percent of
their student body right our kids from
the bottom quarter it's small so we're
not talking about a lot of kids no
we're trying to increase ours of first
generation students we have a program
for an additional scholarship and not
only a scholarship a mentorship program
for them so when they come right they
are mentored by students who are there
and by alumni in all kinds in in social
etiquette in in negotiating
uh an environment that is very different
from the one in which they came so
they're comfortable right they're
they're bright enough to get through to
do well but there are other cultures
there are other cultural issues that are
very challenging right and we need to
provide for that uh and and only if you
do that can they be successful if you
don't do that they flounder on other
domains right absolutely and i think
that's you want them to have uh you know
a good experience a positive experience
and a rich and full experience but
you've got to provide a lot for those i
agree and i think we should i think that
i think we have a responsibility to do
that i agree but i just want to
emphasize it's admirable that you guys
are doing that other places are doing
that
we're never going to be able to educate
the bright low-income kids uh
enough of them at the at the price
private schools right we need to be
right i mean it's just a question of
scale right we need to expand that the
capacity
in america for these kind of students
and i think that that's going to mean
public in public universities i mean
there are hundreds of thousands of smart
poor kids who never get to college at
all right they need to be able to go
to their state institution
uh for you know for a nominal cost and
get a good education some have taken the
route and it's not a bad one of doing
the kind of community college route
right and two years
at a much reduced cost and then
transferring to the flagship university
often it's a good policy i think it's a
it's a good idea
it's i guess i agree with scale i agree
and a few in a few locations i think
tulsa is one of them and perhaps is it
tennessee that are
trying or have already
uh installed a policy of free free
community college
so it's again it's free it's the
beginning of returning to free public
higher ed it's going to cost a lot of
money and it's going to cost a lot but
look what do we want to spend our money
on as a society yeah yeah what what
willing to invest in and we've seen that
american higher education has slipped a
little bit in the kind of national
international rankings although we're
still desirable
it's just like our health care system if
you have a lot of money it's the best in
the world and people from around the
world send their kids more income but in
it our college completion rate used to
be first
and now it's 12th right we need to take
that seriously and if you look at how
many how many years it takes to complete
college i mean yeah georgetown's four
years from virtually everybody but at
other schools it's five and six years uh
and part of that's not access to the
right classes part of that they have to
work while they're there and it's just
it's and it's it's a burden they're
funding issues right they have funding
issues yeah there are both issues that
there's not enough classes for everybody
in certain majors right and that's the
institutions issue and then there are
the economic issues that are challenging
right but the fact that there aren't
enough classes is also a funding issue
right
yes and no i mean that's i mean well
maybe i mean if you if you allow a major
to be the major right exclusively and
you don't direct people to all the
majors of course they'll there's
there'll never be enough room for econ
majors right now as you've suggested in
the book everybody's
like the lemmings they're going in that
direction and it's a there it's a fine
discipline and all but it's not the
exclusive discipline in college it's not
what everybody should be studying right
exactly right everybody should have
there should be a wide variety of things
right so
uh it's important i mean if we're going
to talk about that it's important to
emphasize that it's not just humanities
that have been suffering because
everyone's being told to take
the pragmatic majors econ engineer in
computer science basic sciences there's
been a huge drop in majors in basic
sciences physics chemistry geology
this is really going to cost us
and it's because students are being
steered
by all kinds of pressures including our
president saying don't major in art
history they're being steered into econ
in business and yeah and engineering we
have been uh i mean the national
foundations like asf and so forth have
defunded a lot of the research that's
done for basic sciences
and it's very competitive so it's hard
to maintain a good science faculty who
are able to garner grants to support the
research that they're doing that's
difficult although we have seen a
significant uptick
in stem students uh at our place
particularly in biology uh very very
high right
we had two thousand apple we had twelve
thousand applicants for the college for
eight hundred fifty places last year two
thousand of whom were for biology we
matriculated 90. yeah i think biology is
something that people want biology's
doing very well and right that might be
the
path of pre-med but it's also the path
to a lot of interesting right biotech
biotech things that are so that has not
suffered so much but some others physics
has has uh has um declined somewhat but
physics was never the most popular major
in any campus it was never the most
popular very self-selective but but if
you look at what they call the physical
sciences which is basically science
minus biology
there's been a huge drop and and
yeah part of it is because we're not
funding basic research but that's
that's sort of not an answer that's more
of a problem no and and we need more
people
it's again it's about not making the
investments that are going to keep us
prosperous strong and free
a generation down the line when are you
going to run for congress so that you
can change this
see because you and i sit at this table
will not be able to change that
that dynamic i'm afraid i ranted we
would like to
but really it's a political solution
it's an economically it's a political i
absolutely agree and we probably don't
have the clout to make that well no one
has no no individual has including the
president of the united states
apparently
i think uh five years ago
three years ago no one would have
foreseen
uh the the movement towards the minimum
wage
towards raising the minimum wage getting
the kind of traction it's gotten that's
now as you know in the last election
just passed in several red states
i think that free or low cost public
higher ed
needs to be put on the agenda right next
to raising the minimum wage
uh as as a as a way of addressing the
enormous problem with inequality that
we've finally woken up to in this
country now that we know you know now
that the debt bubble is that's been that
was propping up our prosperity has burst
everyone's looking around in the ruins
realizing we have a huge problem with
inequality and social mobility so that
means raising the minimum wage and it
means making education
accessible again
there's an organization called
it's got a terrible name it's called
redeeming america's promise it's a
terrible name because it doesn't tell
you what it's about but it was started
by a former a2 uh vice president gore
and some other of his political friends
and this is their agenda right it's free
public uh free public higher ed
so the movement is starting
i want more and more people to know
about it i'm listen i'm a writer i'm not
gonna be a politician or even an
organizer
but organizing is what people need to do
and again i want parents to make the
connection between what happens to them
as taxpayers and what happens to them as
tuition payers and to realize that they
have a stake
in resurrecting
public higher ed
uh i think parents are
they if anyone is going to make changes
it's going to be
parents acting
as a group
because they they're fed up as many of
them are
with what's happening with their kids
with the kind of crazy pressure
that their kids are suffering under
there's a documentary called race to
nowhere
that uh it's been circulating in
communities for a long time
gets shown at high schools parents come
they talk about it it was made by a
woman in the bay area who's actually a
lawyer
and her inciting moment was when her
four fourth grade son
was complaining of stomach aches because
he was so stressed
wow about how much homework he had and
she said you know there's a problem here
she started to talk to other parents
you know so that's that that's what i'm
talking about i think that's where
the change will come if it comes at all
the stomach ache comes in more uh
economically advantaged neighborhoods i
think other neighborhoods the stomach
ache will be over other things that the
stomach is empty
and not so much that the blood sugar
absolutely i mean she said she's she's a
lawyer she's an upper middle class
parent so schools are failing in other
places now on the political side
if you if you if you take your argument
what do you defund
or what do you not fund and when when
you uh
when you redirect funds to public
education
i i would raise taxes listen listen not
the top one i think that message will go
over well with everybody in america it's
again you know what you know what i'm
just old enough
to remember the reagan revolution
nobody in their right mind would ever
have imagined that that could have
happened
10 years before it happened that we
would drop top marginal tax rates from
70 to 28 or 35.
i the the one thing i'm certain about
with respect to the future
is that we can't be certain about the
future and things that seem impossible
today like raising the minimum wage
will not will will be possible tomorrow
listen there are plenty of things that i
think we spend too much money on whether
it's prisons or defense or corporate
welfare but we we
our tax rates are historical lows
the share of national income that goes
not to the top 1 to the top 10 and that
includes
me and i'm guessing it includes you and
many of the people we know is
historic highs
we're talking about a transfer of a
couple of trillion dollars a year from
the bottom 90 to the top 10
that's the tax target that i think we
need to go after
and i don't think we'll ever have enough
money for our public needs until we do
i think people in public education will
thank you i think
others will say this is an impossible
mandate i know
it's it's a dilemma it's very difficult
to fund everything at once so
yeah and priorities
yeah of course you know that yeah you
you know that yeah i agree at the same
time
the private schools will continue to
exist they'll still charge hefty
tuitions right they'll be robust they'll
have high demand i don't think that's
going away i just don't think that's
going away that's they're going to be
almost separate tracks well it's part of
the two americas we're creating i mean
people live in gated communities with
private security forces send their kids
to private schools and universities and
they go to yale
yes many of them go to yale
is this the listen i know this is a
cliche but is this the country you want
to live in
uh i certainly think most people don't
because most people are at the short end
of the stick right right most people are
not in that privileged position that's
right
right although some of the people with
whom we deal are in that privileged
position their families are in there
absolutely the kids aren't absolutely
all those kids have a right to be in
these schools too they've earned it they
worked hard and they've done very well
so i don't want to disenfranchise them
and say oh no we'll only take the person
who was in some way disadvantaged to
being part of our
ecosystem that's not fair either no
it's a balance and let's be honest you
can't afford to because no business
model of a private institution requires
rich people paying tuition uh students
and families no question about it
um
well i want to thank you yes this robust
and and stimulating and insightful
conversation uh and i i'm all i can say
is i'm looking forward to your next book
okay okay thank you very much
that was afterwards book tv's signature
program in which authors of the latest
non-fiction books are interviewed by
journalists public policy makers and
others familiar with their material
afterwards airs every weekend on book tv
at 10 pm on saturday 12 and 9 pm on
sunday and 12 a.m on monday
and you can